how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we're still
talking about spider-man
3. it seems like we get some new
information about the upcoming mcu film
every single day now and with the film
officially starting filming
hopefully it's like that for a long time
now but today we have something very
interesting and special something that's
coming not from a scooper or an
inside source but rather a leaked
audition tape that has been taken down
from multiple websites already which
usually means that it's a very
legitimate video now like i said the
video has been taken down but we know
what was on it
and there are some pretty big spoilers
here if this video
is legitimate it'll talk about miles
morales and a
huge spoiler for one of the spider-man
that we'll see in the film
so if you're trying to avoid any and all
spoilers for the upcoming spider-man 3
that's going to take place in the mcu
this may not be the video for
you and you should click away now and
before we get started big
congratulations to joe carcella for
being last week's winner of the iron
spider funko pop just email me in the
email in my description
and i'll get you your prize and since so
many people love this iron spider i'll
be giving it away again
this week just subscribe like the video
and comment down below
so the video has since been deleted
which is kind of always a good sign
because it usually confirms that it's
real but luckily for us
murphy's multiverse.com posted a
description on their website
of everything that was in this leaked
audition tape now disclaimer this
audition tape
is believed to be for miles morales for
spider-man 3 but it is not confirmed to
be that officially
but as you'll see it looks pretty
obvious that it is
the addition video is a two-part video
and the first part begins with a young
african-american man out delivering food
for what appeared to be his parents's
restaurant
the young man is stopped by the nypd
because he is wearing some sort of
spider-man
gear when questioned by the police he
states he's a fan of spidey but it's
clear that in whatever universe this
takes place
being a fan of spidey is not okay and
this clearly
seems to pick up right after the events
of spider-man far from home where
peter parker's identity is revealed
everybody knows he's spider-man
and mysterio framed him so everybody
thinks he's a murderer so
clearly now in the mcu being a fan of
spider-man
isn't really a good thing you're
essentially supporting somebody that
most people think
is a criminal so that would explain why
the nypd stops this young man who is
wearing spider-man clothes
but then we have the second part of this
audition tape
in the first part of the video we see
the young man again in a conversation
with his father and then what is
believed to be his cousin
when talking to the second person
believed to be his cousin a breaking
news report airs on the television
indicating that the costumed
hero spider-man has been found dead at
the museum now this
is severely interesting because if this
is in fact a spider-man 3
audition video it seems like spider-man
is going to die the only question
is which spider-man i think most people
would have a hard time believing that
marvel and sony are going to kill off
tom holland spider-man he's a huge part
of the mcu
he's very loved by all of the fans sony
loves him and
marvel loves him so i really doubt that
they're going to kill him off
but there are many different
possibilities of what could be happening
here
and in a movie where multiple spider-man
are rumored and reported to appear in
there is always the possibility that one
spider-man may in fact
die so there really are a few different
options here and i'm going to go over
the top ones that i think could be
happening
for starters i'll say that they could
kill tom holland and then replace him
with miles morales this is absolutely
absurd i do not think this is going to
happen but i guess it's an option
[Music]
but in more realistic options this could
be a spider-man that is dead
in another universe now we assume that
this character that is being auditioned
for the young african-american man
is miles morales and they could be doing
something similar to what they did
and into the spider-verse where peter
parker dies and then miles morales takes
on the mantle
but of course in a movie where they're
exploring the multiverse he could go
into a different universe
and that's how we could get into the
main tom holland mcu universe
now as far as which spider-man actually
dies in this universe well depends on
what universe they're in
but with rumors of andrew garfield and
toby maguire reprising their spider-man
roles
it could be one of their two universes
so we could get toby maguire spider-man
from the sam raimi universe where he's
still with
mj harry osborne is dead but presumably
spider-man is still out there fighting
crime
until an unfortunate incident happens in
which spider-man
dies and of course the other option is
andrew garfield spider-man from the
amazing spider-man universe
now this would tie the mcu to the
amazing spider-man universe which has
already technically been done and
confirmed
jamie foxx's electro is going to be in
spider-man
3. so there's definitely a big
possibility that this could be andrew
garfield spider-man since elektro is
already heading to our main universe
but an alternate addition of this theory
slash a part
2 could be that tom holland spider-man
actually gets sent to andrew garfield's
amazing spider-man universe
peter is obviously in big trouble in his
own universe he's clearly going to be
wanted by the law perhaps dr strange
sends him to a different universe to get
away for a little bit and
in this universe peter parker has just
died there is no more spider-man
but he can train and teach miles morales
to be the next spider-man
two pretty cool options that we could
see happening especially because
andrew garfield spider-man isn't exactly
everybody's favorite spider-man they
could choose to kill his spider-man
off however let's remember that miles
morales actually does
exist in tom holland's spider-man mcu
universe
in spider-man homecoming donald glover
aka childish gambino played miles
morales uncle
and he mentions miles confirming that he
does exist in the mcu
but that would mean a spider-man in the
main mcu timeline would have to die
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
tom holland's peter parker has to die
this could be the work of doctor strange
it has been confirmed that doctor
strange is going to take on the role of
peter parker's mentor in
spider-man 3. now obviously peter is in
a lot of trouble in the main mcu
timeline
and perhaps a way to get him out of this
trouble is to fake
his death which is something that has
kind of happened in the comics before
between peter parker
and doctor strange and if you think
about it this would be a pretty good
solution to peter parker's problem
if they fake peter parker's death
whether that be by an illusion or doctor
strange pulling his soul
out of his body briefly to convince
people that he's dead
nobody would really be after peter
parker anymore because everybody would
know he's dead
and since spider-man's identity has been
revealed to be
peter parker everybody would think
spider-man is dead as well and now peter
parker only has to change how he looks
just a little bit
get a new identity which probably won't
be too hard considering he knows nick
fury
and he can go about a relatively normal
life continuing to be an avenger
and trying to finish high school since
doctor strange is involved this could be
a way that we go about seeing
spider-man die but of course there is
the possibility that toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man do end up in the main mcu
timeline and
one of them die now this still does
solve peter parker's problem
if toby or andrew died as spider-man of
course they would unmask him and realize
that hey this peter parker kid
isn't spider-man this other random guy
is clearly the spider-man and now
all of a sudden peter parker is clearly
off the hook and technically they could
even say that it
is peter parker that is spider-man just
a different peter parker
and then the last and final option is
that this could be a post-credits scene
for spider-man 3. this could be the
setup for miles morales to eventually
come into the marvel cinematic universe
a lot of people are saying that it's
kind of too soon to bring in miles since
him and tom hall and spider-man are very
similar to each other so perhaps he's
not coming this movie but could be
coming in the future and the very end of
this film
sets it up to where in his universe the
spider-man dies and he
is going to become the new spider-man
now considering the fact that there is a
rumor going around that says miles
morales has actually already been cast
for the spider-man 3 i'd probably say
this is definitely the least likely
well besides tom hall and spider-man
actually dying but it's still
definitely a possibility but which one
of these do you think is most likely to
happen and do you have a theory of your
own
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest spider-man news
and theories and be sure to let me know
what you think is gonna happen in the
comments down below
don't forget to give this video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you